♪ ♪
>> Tyrence: CLIMATE HYSTERIA
WITH RHETORIC.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
GOING BACK ON THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
THE PLANET IN PERIL IN THE PAST,
WHO CAME FORWARD TO SAVE EARTH?
FROM THE SCOURGE OF, IT
TOTALITARIAN REGIMES?
WE CAME FORWARD TO.
>> THE WORLD WILL END IN 12
YEARS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND YOUR BIGGEST
ISSUE IS -- YOUR BIGGEST ISSUE
IS HOW ARE WE GOING TO PAY FOR
IT?
>> YOU CANNOT GO TOO FAR ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE FUTURE OF THE PLANET IS AT
STAKE.
>> Tyrence: AND ELTON
ELIZABETH WARREN CRITICIZE TO
COMPARE HERSELF TO JFK AND USE
ANNIVERSARY OF THEM MOON LANDING
TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS,
JESSE WATTERS?
>> Jesse: THEY JUST SET APOLLO
PROGRAM IS RACIST AND SEXIST
LAST WEEK SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT IS A COMPARISON FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
CORY BOOKER SCARES ME.
HE LOOKED HYSTERICAL --
>> Tyrence: HE WAS FIRED UP.
>> Jesse: I THINK HE NEEDS A
NEW OUTFIT TOO COME WITH A
SWEATER AND BUTTON DOWN COLLAR
EVERYWHERE HE GOES.
WHEN SOMEBODY COMES UP TO ME AND
SAYS GIVE ME ALL YOUR MONEY
WHERE YOU WILL DIE, THAT IS A
SCAM ARTIST.
>> Tyrence: OR A REALLY GOOD
ROBBERY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: AND THAT IS WHAT
THEY ARE DOING PICKING YOU UP
AND RAISING YOUR TAXES.
>> Tyrence: JUAN COMIC YOU
KNOW I LOVE YOU TO DEATH BUT
HERE WE GO.
DO YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS NEED
TO TAKE A PAGE OF THE PLAYBOOK?
THEY ARE FEARMONGERING AND IT IS
TERRIBLE.
REPUBLICANS THE BIG THINK THEY
PUSH TERRORISM AND MADE IT FEEL
LIKE HARASSED OUTSIDE OF YOUR
HOUSE.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING NOW.
AND DEMOCRATS, LIKE THIS.
YOU TELL SOMEBODY IN 12 YEARS
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, WE MIGHT CALL YOU BACK
11 YEARS AND THREE MONTHS AND
SAY, WHAT IS GOING ON?
THEY TRY TO SCARE YOU INTO
THINKING ABOUT THINGS BUT THEY
DON'T DO A GOOD JOB.
THEY GIVE YOU THE SOLUTION.
YOU HAVE TO WORK ON PEER
MONGERING.
TO MAKE US PAY ATTENTION.
>> Juan: WELL MET, IF IT'S
GOING TO TAKE FEARMONGERING.
I THINK PERSONALLY THEY HAVE A
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
THERE'S NOT MUCH DEBATE AMONG
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS A REAL
ISSUE AND WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
SO THEY WERE IN FACT SPEAKING TO
PEOPLE WHO CAN VOTE FOR THEM AND
GIVE THEM A NOMINATION.
I THINK THEY ARE SNEAKING BY THE
WAY TO MOST AMERICANS AT THIS
POINT.
THEY ARE DEAFLY NOT SPEAKING TO
THE HARD RIGHT TROMP CLIMATE
CHANGE DENIERS IF YOU WILL.
>> Tyrence: >> Juan: I DON'T
THINK THERE IS ANYTHING RADICAL
BUT MAYBE
THEY NEED TO RAMP UP FEARMONGERI
THEY NEED TO RAMP UP FEARMONGERG
BUT THAT TO ME --
>> Jesse: THERE IS NOTHING
RADICAL ABOUT THE GREEN NEW
DEAL?
>> Juan: NO.
>> Jesse: IT'S $129.
>> Dagen: JUAN COME I WOULD
HAVE MORE INTEREST IN THAT LINE
OF THINKING IF IT WERE ABOUT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A J
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A B
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A S
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A P
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A O
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A R
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A M
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A ,
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A D
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A C
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A R
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A E
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A F
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A R
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A A
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A L
GREEN NEW DEAL, BUT THAT WAS A ,
ALL THIS STUFF AND
BERNIE SANDERS SAY AGAIN THAT
THERE IS NO BILL TOO BIG IN
ORDER TO TACKLE CLIMATE CHANGE
BUT TACKLING EVERYTHING ELSE BUT
CLIMATE CHANGE WITHOUT.
>> Juan: THERE WAS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THERE BUT AS YOU
POINT OUT A LOT OF THE KITCHEN
SINK IN THERE.
>> Dagen: THAT IS TOO MUCH
KITCHEN SINK AND NOT ENOUGH
SPONGE.
>> Juan: LET'S HAVE A
CONVERSATION RATHER THAN ZERO
LIKE THE REPUBLICANS?
>> Dagen: IT'S NOT IRRATIONAL
CONVERSATION WHICH IS THE
PROBLEM.
IT IS AN EMOTIONAL CONVERSATION.
I WANT TO ADDRESS SOMETHING
ELIZABETH WARREN SAID.
ELIZABETH WARREN AND CORY BOOKER
ARE TRYING TO EVOKE THESE
MEMORIES OF WORLD WAR II AND
SOME OF THE INCREDIBLE HISTORY
THAT WE HAVE WITH MILITARY AND
THE SPACE PROGRAM.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
APOLLO PROGRAM AND NOW,
ELIZABETH WARREN IS SAYING WE
ALL CAME TOGETHER AND WE GOT
GUYS ON THE MOON.
AND THAT WAS PRETTY HISTORIC 50
YEARS AGO.
A PHENOMENAL FEAT THAT JFK
CALLED OUT 1961 AND BY THE END
OF THE DECADE WE WOULD HAVE A
MAN ON THE MOON AND THAT
HAPPENED.
YOU HAVE TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO DO THAT AND
THESE PEOPLE CANNOT EXIST.
THE POLITICAL CAREER CANNOT
EXIST AND LESS CONSTANT DIVISION
AND ELIZABETH WARREN,
BERNIE SANDERS, THAT IS
"THE SQUAD," THE PRESIDENT COME
I WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
THERE IS NO WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
COME TOGETHER WHEN YOU LIVE FOR
PUSHING THEM APART.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND HOW WAS
IT PUSHING THEM APART --
>> Tyrence: YOU TAKE IT HOME.
YOU THINK OF MOONSHINE EXPERTS
ON THIS.
COMPARING YOURSELF TO ANYONE
LIKE JFK, SHE HAS A BAD --
THINGS DON'T PLAY WELL TO HER
WHEN SHE COMPARES.
>> Dagen:
>> Wagen:
>> WASen:
>> WASHI:
>> WASHING HER DOG WITH A HOSE,
THAT CAUGHT FIRE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THEY ARE LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF THEY WANT TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE, WE WILL ALL PAY SIX TO
$10 PER GALLON FOR GASOLINE,
PERIOD.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DRIVE A
CAR OF OUR CHOOSING.
WE WILL HAVE TO DRIVE A VEHICLE
THAT ACTUALLY MIGHT PRODUCE CO2
EMISSIONS IN MAKING IT BECAUSE
OF THE BATTERY AND BECAUSE OF
THE COAL REQUIRED TO PRODUCE THE
ELECTRICITY USED TO CHARGE THE
CAR.
IT WILL HURT THE POOR.
IT WILL HURT THE WORKING MAN AND
WOMAN WHO HAS TO DRIVE TWO HOURS
ROUND-TRIP TO GET TO THEIR JOB.
STOP LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CHANGE THE CAR THAT
WE DRIVE AND CHANGE HOW WE
CREATE ELECTRICITY, WE WILL ALSO
PUT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK.
HOW DID THAT WORK OUT FOR
HILLARY CLINTON, SPEAKING OF THE
COAL MINERS, WE WILL PUT THE
COAL MINERS OUT OF WORK.
YEAH, THAT REALLY, REALLY --